what's your
thoughts on the potential of unreal
engine 5
do you see it as completely
game-changing
um i mean it's doing
i i don't use off-the-shelf engines
right i'm a do-it-yourself kind of guy
part of what i value in having our own
company is the ability to craft
something technically that will do
exactly what we want right um
i think engines like that are useful for
a lot of people obviously um
with unreal i think that they're
they're
like
the stuff they showed off this year if
it was this year and not late last year
i've sort of lost
my remembrance of when they announced
like the nanite stuff and all that um
i mean i think that's just the latest
in
the kind of unreal engine playbook that
they've been following
um
since the beginning really
so that's been successful for them
obviously right like they build
things that look really good um
people want to use those things in their
games and so they license the engine and
this is uh another step of that it is
another step of that in a time when it's
harder to do so that's really
interesting like in the early days of
games
in the very beginning
it was just people like mostly john
carmack um
figuring out how to do stuff in 3d at
all in real time right but then once we
kind of had the basics of that
um
there was a great deal of like computer
graphics research that had been done
that was still mostly too slow for real
time but that
we could figure out how to
incorporate elements of and and go
forward right and so we kind of had a
road map for a while like oh how do we
do
more complex reflectance models but do
that in real time on the hardware that
we have and that's a very concrete
problem right
um
now it's like
well we kind of caught up with
everything that's obviously good like
you know
something like a pixar movie does do way
more expensive rendering than we do but
it's unclear how much of that is really
conducive to real time and
whatever and um so
there's not like a clear road map
anymore like there used to be and so if
this is your job is to advance the field
now you're kind of striking out in your
own direction and so that's what they've
been doing here and
it looks like they've been doing that
successfully we'll see
i think there's some downsides to that
kind of model that they were advertising
um
just practical downsides in terms of how
do you make a game but
that's also what i thought when they
gave the demos
for what became gears of war i was like
i don't know how i would ever deal with
this and then that became industry
standard so we'll see
i was looking up some of the tech demos
on that night it seems like what's being
done is revolutionary and i don't know
i don't know what it is what that secret
sauce is that allows them to render so
many polygons
they've actually published some
technical papers that explain it right i
think they're so not worried about
other engines catching up to them that
they're just like here's how we do it
mostly because a lot of in something
like that
a lot of what makes it work is just that
you got in there and really figured out
like hundreds of little practical
problems right and they probably didn't
publish all those
because how would you right um
but yeah i think there are some
relatively in-depth explanations if
you're interested now do you see that as
game changing outside of the visual
aspects like it's visual eye candy do
you see it as actually changing the
mechanics of the game or the way that
either that it saves developers time so
they could spend it elsewhere or they
can use it to tell us
yeah no design wise i don't see an
obvious thing that that does
it's an obvious increase in the visual
fidelity that you could have in a scene
right
that said
like the way that they pitched it in at
least one of the things that i saw was
hey your artists don't have to deal with
all these level of detail tools and
whatever
they can just
dump this source polygons that they're
working with into the game and run with
that and on the one hand that sounds
very easy right on the other hand that
sounds like a giant pain in the ass
because now the amount of data that i
have in source control is like
several orders of magnitude bigger and
like that becomes its own
like i want to see what people do about
that right um
that said it well and also it does seem
a little bit impractical for most games
um
just because it's a little too high end
but that's the history of all these
things is they get built they get
announced
they're probably too slow to really use
right now but then next generation or a
few years go by and things get faster
and
then
you know so that's the same playbook
that's been going on for a long time now
that said systems aren't getting as much
faster over time as they used to
um but still yeah i don't know like i
would just like to see i'm interested to
see what they do with it and where they
go with it